[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] them
[Music]
it's Thursday April 6th
we have big breaking
not so surprising news Clarence Thomas
takes millions in luxury gifts
from a Texas GOP Mega donor
of course he does why
yeah I mean you know I understand this
just being ungovered
but are we really surprised
that Clarence Thomas is in the pack
pocket of a mega donor
are are we is this we're supposed to be
like oh my God I mean
the president that he tried to protect
that his wife
helped fund the coup
it declarance Thomas's wife
help fund the coup attempt
for Donald Trump that [__] traitor
is now
kremely charged in the state of New York
Presumed Innocent
on 34 counts
of falsifying business records to cover
up a crime which is a felony 34 felonies
to be exact
for hush money payments to win an
election
you know
we we had Senator Doug Jones on
yesterday it was a great interview
a great interview I I never actually
thought that I would get a senator or a
former Senator on my show but the
stature of Doug Jones Come on the guy
beat Roy Moore you remember that race
that special election it was huge I I I
I I actually am sad that I didn't get a
chance to talk to him yesterday about
that race I would I would love to have a
conversation with Senator Jones about
that race
I watched it every step of the way every
every single time Doug or Roy Moore got
in front of a camera I was watching that
race
it's so important
about what our politics is about but
that's what I want to tell you is
everything all of it is politics oh this
is a political investigation yeah no
[__] Sherlock
Donald Trump was running in I don't know
an election to be uh what do they call
him politician
it was it was politics he used hush
money which I actually don't believe is
illegal
I know a lot of people will disagree and
they they talk about the John Edwards
trial and different things and McDonald
but honestly
honestly right now in this country to be
quite honest and Clarence Thomas has
made the decision on McDonald
the former governor of Virginia who was
she was charged and convicted
with political bribes
bribes
and he appealed to the Supreme Court and
won
they overturned his conviction
because there are political bribes in
this country
now some people do it legally even
though it might not be ethical
and others commit 34 felonies doing it
because they want to deduct it on their
taxes or they want the cash to look like
it came for their business or whatever
they're trying to cover up the crime
that they thought was a crime
right but with the intent it doesn't
have to be a crime the intent just has
to be covering up a crime possibly
but it's a question it's a question we
should answer in this country
our our political bribes legal are they
legal should we allow them like these
are questions we should probably answer
especially
from a lifetime appointment bench seat
on the Supreme Court of the United
States of America
the beacon
of Justice are you serious
what the [__] man listen we got a long
ways to go
Like the Wolf is in the hen house the
fascists are everywhere they're [__]
there I don't know if you're watching
what's happening in Tennessee people are
pissed off in Tennessee they're [__]
pissed
and they're going to the Capitol and
making sure that those legislators know
they're pissed that they're trying to
silence their voices
they're going to vote to expel three
members I'm not sure what time that vote
is
um
but uh uh representative Jones just came
out not too long ago Tennessee hollers
on this uh speaking of Tennessee holler
the the founder of Tennessee holler
Justin apparently there was gunshots
fired at his home
and in the recent days
but Tennessee holler is there at the
Capitol and they're posting videos
online so we're gonna watch a lot of
that video today
but we got a long ways to go
because the fascists are right at our
front door
and they're not they're not like trying
to disguise themselves as something else
they're out right [__] fascist
and this morning we wake up and we we
come to the realization that our Supreme
Court Justices which is not again it's
this is not surprising
that Clarence Thomas has taken GOP Mega
donor money
I guess what would be surprising is
maybe seeing other justices
receiving this kind of treatment but not
Clarence Thomas and [__] no that's not
surprising at all
I mean to wake up and even think that
that would be news I mean yeah it's all
over the place
maybe we should be paying attention more
to like not just one but all federal
judges all of them
and what they can and cannot receive
without disclosure because that's the
thing here
it's I don't know that I'm mad that some
Mega donor was given Clarence Thomas a
bunch of money
but shouldn't it be disclosed shouldn't
we know this
this is someone who gets a lifetime
appointment and they never have to tell
us when they're getting political bribes
excuse me a legend I mean listen
Clarence Thomas did not give a statement
for this article
the the Texas GOP Mega donor I'm sh you
know I don't know this guy I forget the
guy's name in the article
but I want to call him Yosemite Sam
that's kind of the
I don't know this image I have in my
head I guess
the rats will be Mormon
you know what I mean yeah that kind of
[__]
that's what I got in my head
but Clarence Thomas taking these gifts
and and what they what they called it
was Hospitality right oh well we give
this this type of hospitality to all our
friends oink like all the politicians
and all the people of power that we
entertain I mean you're talking about
Yachts you're talking about Mega
vacations you're talking about huge
Resorts that these people are going to
and they're all doing the other Guides
of hospitality like oh look these are my
friends and I paid for my friends to go
everywhere with me I mean I'm super rich
so I can just pay for everyone no
problem I'll pick up the tab but the
problem isn't that they that he paid
Clarence Thomas
I'm I'm not I'm not saying I'm against
politicians taking big money big money
as long as we get to know it right I
mean if we can know who's giving who
money can't you go well then you're not
going to be that anymore
but with Clarence Thomas we can't
[__] do that
we can't vote him out
he doesn't have a term
and everyone's standing around wondering
what's wrong with right right-wing
politics in this country
liberals liberals
rather no matter what party they're in
Liberals are trying to work which there
are very few [__] people who believe
in Liberal democracy in the Republican
party anymore they're all [__]
fascist
there's few not a lot I mean a couple
I'm talking maybe three or four elected
officials around the country
so bad it's gotten
but Liberals are trying to figure out
what to do for the American people right
how could we lower health care costs how
can we make sure that people don't go
broke because of a medical bill for
crying out loud
can can we get wages up
to keep up with inflation what's the
best we can do to make sure the
unemployment number is as low as it
possibly could get
what do we do about education are we
funding enough education are kids
getting educated enough
it's quite an investment for our country
we need to make sure their their
educated maybe like start school at
three instead of five
and then the parents won't even have to
pay for daycare that'll help too
you know [__] like that making sure
insulin is 35 for everybody
oh and by the way Social Security
Medicare Medicaid not only do they want
it funded they want to they want to make
sure to keep it for people who need it
schweitz called the safety net but you
know whatever
these are radical things that the
Liberals are trying to do
radical [__] radical stuff you know just
the [__] that all Americans actually
[__] want
Americans don't want to go in the
grocery store and be worried about
someone mowing them down with a goddamn
weapon of War because some [__]
trumped up white dudes got a hard on for
guns
okay they just we just we're over it
even people who like [__] guns aren't
or don't want you just that let anyone
and everyone have a [__] gun you
[__] it's not it's not rocket surgery
it really isn't
it's not hard to understand these things
and in Tennessee that's all people are
asking for they're not asking you to
[__] go house by house and and demand
that they hand over their weapons or
their guns they just they what they just
want you to [__] know who's buying
them
that that's it that that's all they want
they just want to make sure people know
who the [__] is buying them that is that
the least we could do Jesus Christ you
can't even walk into a goddamn Pharmacy
where I'm at
and buy [__] Benadryl
or Sudafed excuse me
you can't go buy Sudafed
you can't go buy it I mean you can
they'll give a little bit to you but you
can't go down the [__] road to
another Pharmacy your ID's already in
they won't give you any more of the [__]
because methamphetamine makes people
crazy
are you [__] kidding me
and they're going to expel these three
members
for having voice for their constituents
which is going to silence the people
that are there at the Capitol
I thought I thought the GOP was against
cancer culture that's what I thought
maybe I'm wrong
now why don't I sound saddened about
this
folks this is an exercise in democracy
that's exactly what this is in Tennessee
it's exactly what happened in Wisconsin
this week it's exactly what happened in
the Chicago election what happened in
2022 in the midterms what happened in
2020 these are all political exercises
and we got to get in shape in this
country our our political Fitness is
[__] weak at best
we really have to work this muscle of
civics
it is enough of this [__] people need to
start realizing that we can't just wish
away
what we want done
we have to be loud and we have to be
proud
about our liberal views and show them
the strength of democracy show it to
them show it to them
maybe they'll finally [__] understand
like people like Clarence Thomas
thinking thinking no one will ever find
out that he was receiving luxury gifts
from some [__] billionaire down in
Texas
and not disclosing it to us
his [__] boss
these people don't realize who they work
for
they don't know
you you're telling me
that I'm supposed to believe
that Clarence Thomas received all these
luxury millions of dollars millions of
dollars not in cash but millions of
dollars you could Hey listen you
couldn't go [__] where that guy was
going without a bunch of [__] money
you couldn't you would you wouldn't be
able to ride on those boats getting
those planes stay at those Resorts
without stacks of cash
but Clarence Thomas
a Supreme Court Justice
is gonna behind our back think that
we're not gonna [__] We're Not Gonna
publicly hold you accountable now there
ain't a goddamn thing we can do about
his seat
we gotta wait that out
we gotta let we we gotta let nature take
its course there
cause I don't know if you notice but
there ain't enough goddamn votes get
[__] done in Washington because we keep
failing
we keep failing to fight like I've said
before do you know how to end
gerrymandering I mean I have people come
at me all the time at the gerrymander
that you want to know you want to know
the solution to gerrymandering I'll give
it to you I'll tell you exactly how to
solve gerrymandering over the next 10
years
I'll give you my plan right here
Democrats and blue States need to
gerrymander the [__] [__] out of
their states gerrymander the [__] out of
them
there shouldn't be one goddamn red
District in them entire [__] blue
States [__] [__] them [__] em
gerrymander the [__] at him go all the
way up to the edge of the law and hop
over it [__] them
that's what we should be doing
the day here's why let me let me give
you the reason why because you're like
oh my God oh my God listen to what
Tony's saying yep I'm saying it out loud
I'm saying the quiet part out loud folks
let me tell you something the day the
day that Mark Elias has to file a
lawsuit against Democrats
because they're gerrymandering too much
that's the day Republicans will stop
gerrymandering
when Mark Elias is on their side
trust me all right I'm telling you
when Republicans know that they won't be
able to get away with it anymore they'll
be like oh man we really oh well I tell
you what we what we need to do make sure
no one gerrymanders this gerrymander is
getting out of control We're not gonna
have control of anything
you goddamn right you're not
that's what we should do
we we have to lean into democracy folks
we have to lean into the politicization
of this stuff folks we can't be scared
anymore we can't be this oh we're scared
to offend and scared to [__] get
people oh man we might we might scare
people away from our big tent party [__]
out of here with that nonsense
the American people are for red flag
laws and background checks
the [__] that the people at the Capitol
in Tennessee
are protesting for they're for it
everywhere I don't give a [__] what
state you're in I don't care I don't
care if you think there's all kinds of
guns and there's all kinds of gun nuts
and two abroads there ain't enough of
them trust me
there ain't
even the ones that have guns want to
make sure that they don't get in the
hands of someone they shouldn't be in
hands of at a bare minimum
if it saves one [__] life it's worth
it
especially if it saves three children
and three teachers wives in Nashville
or 19 children down in Uvalde
or at Newtown or at Parkland on and on
it [__] goes
so yeah it's worth it even to the people
who own and like guns it's worth it
but we have to test them out we have to
test it
we have to test democracy and we do that
by using it they're trying to use
democracy to kill our Republic
Jesus Christ they're going to vote to
expel three members in Tennessee in the
Tennessee legislator today
because they don't like they don't like
that people are listening to them
they don't like people are listening to
them and the people they represent are
coming to the Capitol to protest they
don't like that
and we're gonna stand back and just and
just watch
the Republicans say ah that Trump
indictment is political
he's a Soros he's a Soros bot prosecutor
okay we get what you're saying there you
anti-semites and here's the thing
your Supreme Court Justice who's making
decisions for our country has bought and
paid for you [__]
bought and paid for not enough of the
Soros bought judges you [__] buffoons
enough of that garbage
billionaires billionaires listen to me
billionaires by judges
there's a good example in the news this
morning
you [__] right-wing nut jobs
go look
and billionaires give to all kinds of
political causes
good ones bad ones
some horrible
most of them really [__] bad
for the people that is I mean they're
great for the [__] billionaires I
mean why do you think they're not
getting why do you think they're not
giving them all your money
but we've had to listen to Grandpa poopy
pants in the entirety of trump
megalodites
the real America First Nazi party
for weeks talked about talk about a
democrat-backed D.A in Manhattan
and all the oh the judge the judge in
Trump's case gave 20 bucks gave twenty
dollars to Democrats
so the judge gave money to Democrats but
the judge on the Supreme Court who got
millions of dollars
oh [__] they're just gonna Overlook that
that [__] that
do you see why I'm not so damn pissed
off this morning
that I'm kind of excited about this
do you know how bad this again makes the
plot slip right through their hands
slip right through their hands
how how many how many times did you hear
in December of 2020 how the Supreme
Court was gonna overturn to make Donald
Trump the president
you remember that
and the Supreme Court said no no and no
and it was bought and paid for
it was bought and paid for
and they still said no they weren't
gonna do it
and we're supposed to believe because
George Soros gave a pack a Super PAC
some money which is completely legal
and that pack donated to dozens of D.A
campaigns and one of them happened to be
Alvin Bragg that that George Soros has
some kind of magical power over Alvin
Bragg we know what you're saying we're
you're saying that George Soros is
Jewish we we know what you're saying
we we see what you're we see what you're
saying
because this morning Clarence Thomas
has found out that a big huge mega donor
in Texas was giving him millions of
dollars in resorts
Yachts plane tickets vacations meals and
you [__] not a [__] sound
not a not a [__] not even a peep
out of you [__]
so when we say you're being anti-semitic
when you say Sorrows back politicians
Soros fat D.A Soros back judge we know
what you're saying
that's why we know that's how we get the
evidence
but we have to stand to stand the
defense of our democracy We the People
that's right we have to engage in our
democracy like I've been telling the
last few days now it's the time
now is the time to get loud and proud
like they are in Tennessee
now is the time
to sacrifice everything we got in our
democracy to save it
it is a thing that will bring us Liberty
our freedom and our rights
so what do you choose to do
because that's the heart of liberalism
is choice
what will you choose to do will you
choose to use your microphone I choose
to use mine every single weekday two
full hours noon Eastern 11 Central 9
Pacific you know me
I'm not gonna stop
no matter what the challenges
and there's audio challenges
maybe timing maybe I had a little bit
too much the night before
I could lose my voice doesn't matter I'm
here
what are you gonna do
how are you going to make your
microphone heard
because that's what it's about folks
is we got to put our microphones
together and they have to be singing and
one proud loud voice
democracy over autocracy
liberalism over fascism
that is what we need to be yelling and
screaming day in and day out just like
they are down in Tennessee
just like they did this week in
Wisconsin
they showed up and they made their
microphone heard
by marking their ballot 11 [__]
points
I'm telling you
the wind of Liberty is at our backs
folks we must open up the sails of
democracy it is time now to engage and
to beat these sons of [__] in 2024
and we're at we're we're in the election
they've already told us that they've
already said that oh we're in an
election you can't you can't indict him
we're in an election he announced like
three days after the lack selection you
[__] chuckleheads when aren't we in
an election then when can we prosecute
criminals that want to run for president
oh speaking of that right before I go to
break did you did you see
that RFK Jr is gonna is gonna run for
president of the United States oh I
can't wait to dig in on the libtards on
that one that's right hey you people out
there that don't want Joe Biden to be
the nominee there's your guy there's
your guy there's your guy
that's how serious it's gonna be I told
you this I tried to tell you I've been
telling you for weeks to forget about a
Challenger in the Democratic Party
but here you are you won't listen to me
and here's RFK Jr right there right
there to fill that Gap everybody make
sure you're subscribed to the Tony
Michaels podcast channel here on YouTube
it's free free 99 that cost you a single
nickel also download every single
episode every single weekday of the Tony
Michaels podcast on Apple Spotify and
Google hell just download them on all
those things
give us a great review while you're
there following us also follow us on
Facebook if you still have a Facebook
account at the Tony Michaels and check
out all the stuff there and also link
your Amazon Prime account to your Twitch
account you have one free subscription
with your Amazon Prime account if you
link it to your Twitch account we get a
few dollars of Amazon's money and it
doesn't cost you a single thing because
you get a free subscription so go right
now and link your Amazon Prime account
to your Twitch account
and give us that one free subscription
we got a lot of them over there now and
oh and by the way I want to remind you
you have to renew it every month so you
have to re-give it every month so if you
haven't remembered to
renew your subscription to our Channel
go over to your Twitch app or your
Amazon Prime app and renew your
subscription to the Tony Michaels
podcast on Twitch
I got some videos to show you from
Tennessee so don't go anywhere stick
around we'll be right back right after
this
we'll be right back Mark
60 seconds this is the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
I've always wanted to learn a new
language but whenever I try it never
sticks so when Babel made a MAG Edition
I knew I had to give it a try Babel Maga
Edition makes it really easy to learn
and there's lots of lessons to choose
from like subtly racist to full-blown
white supremacists the first lesson
began with learning simple phrases and
soon I was putting those words and
phrases into a conversation each lesson
takes about 10 to 15 minutes to complete
and they're all really different which
keeps things interesting the app is
really smart it actually keeps track of
the words that I'm struggling with I
chose Babble mag Edition because it's
created by smart white people like me
and now I can't wait to explore meet new
friends and use my new Mega skills with
my in-laws all lives matter
[Music]
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome back to the show get in that
chat and in the chat and show some loves
to our moderators the best moderators in
the world Cynthia Amanda Deidra Mighty
librarian Margie MJ they're there too I
don't know if they're here today Robin
over on Twitch
get in the chat
there's some love to the moderators I
know you got you guys always give love
to the monaries look at the end the end
of the show you're like yeah I see you
Tony and Gabe hey see you moderators The
Mod Squad
you guys love our moderators here you
love our chat here
it's one of the most engaged chants
on one of the smallest shows
we're getting bigger though so um I got
a report the other day from YouTube from
the month of March they sent me an email
and uh you know last month we dealt with
a seven day suspension
we had a seven ooh got slapped on the
hand for seven days on YouTube I
couldn't I couldn't broadcast from the
Tony Michaels YouTube channel for seven
days
listen to this listen to this number we
had
4.7 million minutes viewed
can you believe that almost 5 million
minutes viewed in the month of March
on the Tony Michaels podcast YouTube
channel and we were we were suspended
for seven days
that's [__] crazy
I I've been telling you guys for many
months that our audience is getting
bigger and bigger but the thing that is
happening with our show the thing that
happens with our show is the audience
watches from the moment that it starts
until it ends
the whole thing
the entirety of the two hours you guys
would love for it to be three hours I I
I'm sure if I went to the chat there'd
already be someone who said three hours
three hours three hours probably Amanda
I see you Amanda
what you guys watch from the very
beginning to the very end
I I mean I believe that there's a reason
but it's because this chat is so engaged
it is because the content that we create
here is so engaging
I try to make the a block very cathartic
I think I succeed
I try to make the rest of the show very
entertaining I want you guys to have fun
when we have to
deal with the craziness that is going on
in our country
but the conversation that happens is so
important
that's why when we have a very
a very unique troll in the chat we like
to bring them up I like to give them
[__] I like to show them how it is I
want them to stick around
when you guys are being hilarious in the
chat in that matter how in the gutter it
may be
sometimes the funniest part
but no no matter how much in the gutter
it may be you guys are hilarious in the
chat we have one of the funniest
audiences
in the world
and I appreciate every single one of you
every single minute that you watched
last last month to the tune of almost
five million of them
you are the best audience in the world
we only have I think we got the was it
15 000 just over 15 000 subscribers here
a lot of people like Jesus Christ why
don't you have more I'm like I I don't
know I say it every day to subscribe
and we get new and new viewers every
single day
and those viewers turn into twice a week
viewers and then everyday viewers and
then they can't stop watching a single
minute of this thing
I mean imagine imagine for a minute if
we had a hundred thousand subscribers
how many minutes would be watched
I mean you're automatically well let's
say 150 that's a 10x of how many
subscribers we have right now
can you imagine that 50 50 million
minutes is what it would be
if we just 10xed everything because I
believe that will happen with this
channel I see a lot of channels out
there that get two three four five
hundred thousand subscribers
and they get a lot of views
on their videos but it's not near the
ratio that we have like you're not near
it not even close
not even close
but that's because you're the best
audience in the world
and you're one of the most engaged
audiences in the world
right here and I say world because we
got people who view this all around the
world
all around the world there's people
right now in Australia The Sun Ain't
Even up in that [__] yet
probably and they're watching and
listening to this show right now
I'm telling you
there's something happening
in our country there's something
happening in our world
and there's a need for that cathartic
release
so don't touch that dial that's they
would say in the old days don't change
the channel
every single weekday
noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific here
on YouTube so I will ask you once again
subscribe to the Tony Michaels YouTube
channel also share it share it with
folks or if you're on Twitch or Facebook
hell wherever it's at share it on your
social media let's make this audience
huge for 2024.
because the more people we get engaged
in our chat and in our show and our
conversation that we're having don't you
think that will be good for democracy
think about when we bring Rachel
bittickoff or Senator Doug Jones like we
did yesterday with their Great and
Powerful messages imagine imagine what
could happen if we had a hundred
thousand people viewing live I think
it's possible
I think it's possible to get a hundred
thousand people viewing live don't you
I think a hundred thousand people would
watch this show especially I know a
hundred thousand people would love to
see this face no no not this face I'm
talking about this other face that
appears on this show here it is uh oh
that what there it is hey that face a
hundred thousand people would like to
see this face every day would they I
don't know 100 000 people that's a lot
of people man
no I I and listen I think by sometime
next year the Tony Michaels podcast here
every single weekday will have at least
a hundred thousand people watching
April 6th Thursday 12 37. p.m Eastern
Tony calling it calling it yeah go ahead
and Mark that time stamp down if you
want if you want we got a guest today
but you want to show a uh a video
beforehand is that is that right yeah
yeah the woman do you got a link to um
is it the new what was that yep it is
the new one all right so so let's we're
gonna we're gonna watch the new what was
that it's about eight minutes she said
is that what you said yeah it's eight
minutes okay it's about eight minutes
we're gonna watch the new what was that
I think we're gonna start trying to do
that a little bit show that video here
on the show why not play that clip you
know yeah yeah should we get should we
get like a sound effect or something
yeah just get you know I think we should
we should run up run up a whole uh
soundboard on this oh really yeah why
not why you know what one time I wanted
fart noises but I just I just use my
math why do you why do you need to play
a button if you can just do it yourself
I got a pretty good I got a pretty good
fart button you know what I mean I got
it I got different ones too you know
there's the wet one yeah there's the dry
one there's a long one there's a squeaky
you know yeah yeah is that is that what
it says that's sometimes what it says
okay so this is the new uh what was that
so tell me a little bit about this uh
what's the context of this new what was
that yeah so this what was that is uh is
Jared Moskowitz you know why you don't
who is a uh representative from Parkland
and some of you may know Parkland as the
park you know where the Parkland school
shooting was so if there's anyone who's
going to talk on the topic of of
shootings and gun violence like this is
someone who is not going to have a
little bit of knowledge because right
yeah a first-hand experience other than
Margie Taylor green and so Martin Taylor
green you know challenges back at Jared
Moskowitz in in this clip and I dig in
to the lie that Margaret Taylor green uh
talks about and I expose some people
know some basic stuff but I dig in and
reveal some other stuff that not a lot
of not a lot of people are talking about
I'm sorry I said we had the funniest
audience in the world and they're
they're talking about the fart noises
we're trying to look look we're trying
to promote games what was that and we
got hung up on the fart noises the
chance just you know that's how our
that's how our people are that's how it
works it sometimes turns into the gutter
so well we're going to show this uh what
was that here but I think we're gonna do
this more and more because I want to
show the what was that on the show we
used to show them on the show but you
started making so many of us there's a
lot of them showing them here on the
show and I want to tell you folks that
what you should do uh if you liked the
what was that because this is the piece
of content that Gabe does extras for
over on patreon so if you like this
content that you're about to see when
you're when you're when you're done with
the show here go to what was
thatshow.com what was that show.com
it'll take you directly to Gabe's
patreon where he he uh gives you extras
the behind the scenes some bloopers you
do an a weekly q a and like a Roundup
thing
um so you get all kinds of extras over
there on his patreon and it helps
support this content which is so
important so because I mean what we do
here is is all independent right there's
no George Soros funded operation as much
as I [__] Republicans would love to
say that we are I would take his money I
would take his money hell I would take
that money I would disclose it I'd put
Soros propaganda down at the bottom oh
yeah yeah if he would if he would send
me if he would send me a check every
month hell yeah wow yeah I'm not like
Clarence Thomas I would totally disclose
it oh yeah yeah I mean I don't receive
money like that I would disclose it yeah
I would be transparent easily easily
easily right I mean we're transparent
about the money we get we get money from
patreon that's how we make our living we
sell merch we get money from that we
sell the hats right some people give us
just money in a tip jar well you know
that we're transparent about it we're
not like Clarence Thomas and Republicans
right we're not like Donald we're not
trying to commit fraud to cover up
people giving us money not trying to be
Shady right and and saying oh this is
not where I got my money or
we are completely funded by the audience
right and the fans so we appreciate it
yeah it goes a long way I actually he's
actually the person eating a meal you
know well I prefer it that way don't you
because the audience the people that are
our bosses are the people listening to
us right that makes the most amount of
sense which is another thing too like if
you on my patreon you know I'll I'll uh
periodically ask like here are some
things that are on my radar what are
some things that you would like me to
dig in oh yeah so so if there's a
subject that that some of the viewers
want to see you do what was that on then
they kind of give you those suggestions
yeah hey that's pretty cool that's
pretty cool you know let's watch yeah
well you know let's watch the latest uh
what was that and then uh we'll we'll
talk more about it on the other side
hunt with an AR-15 with a deer because
there's nothing left and there's nothing
left of these kids when people go into
school and murder them while they're
trying to read you guys are worried
about banning books kids can't read wait
what was that dead kids can't read
Marjorie Taylor green thought it was a
smart idea to challenge the congressman
from Parkland on the issue of school
shootings and I think it's safe to say
it did not go well for her
[Music]
Marjorie Taylor green and her three
little toes really stepped in it this
time the heated exchange started with
representative Jared Moskowitz stating
the facts about gun violence and calling
out the Republican party's hypocrisy 550
people have been murdered in school
who cares about the cars
what about the kids
no hearing for them
338 000 kids have experienced gun
violence in this country
the number one killer of school-aged
children in this country
gun violence
how do you think for the parents
who have had to bury their kids who have
had to decide
what to put their kids kind of clothes
to put their kids in when they bury them
or kind of box they have to pick out
for their child or for when they come
home
and that room in their house is empty
what do you think about for the parents
who have all their kids stuff
and they don't know what to do with it
what do you think about the parents no
high school graduation no college
graduation no wedding no grandkids no
future what do you think those parents
who have buried their kids think that
we're holding a hearing to talk about DC
public urination you know speaking of
crime
Republican on Republican crime
former president Donald Trump held a
rally in Waco Texas with his Rasputin
Ted Nugent he said the number one
national security threat to this great
nation
isn't Russia or China or DC crime
but is an 81 year old slip and fall
Survivor in minority leader Mitch
McConnell
I'm just wondering if you know we're
going to find time in between you know
some folks here attending the next rally
to celebrating Timothy McVeigh if we're
going to find time to hold the hearing
on mass murder in schools when are we
having that hearing we want to talk
about crime and murder
let's have a hearing on murder in
schools it's murder is there any any
question I'll yield to anyone on this
committee who disagrees that murder in
schools is not murder I yield regardless
of where you sit on the political
Spectrum Right Center or left I hope we
can all agree that murder in schools is
still murder and there should be no
debate about it however the pathological
line gun-loving idiot Marjorie Taylor
green took moskowitz's bait and opened
her mouth and I'll yield to anyone on
this committee who disagrees that murder
in schools is not murder will you yield
oh I'll yield yes please the fact that
Marjorie Taylor green is challenging the
congressman from Parkland Florida is
unbelievable
but also believable yeah I was when I
was in 11th grade and Joe Biden made our
schools gun-free school zones one of the
students in my school brought three guns
to school and our entire school went on
lockdown because he was the only person
with a gun there was no good guy with a
gun to protect us kids at school you
want to know why the shooter is dead in
Nashville the trans shooter you want to
know why because a good guy with a gun
killed that woman she identified as a
man she was mentally ill probably taking
hormones and she went in and murdered
children and adults in this Christian
school in Nashville so if you want to
have a good talk about schools and
protecting children we need to talk
about protecting our children the same
way we protect our President we protect
our celebrities
okay honestly I was surprised that Marge
knew how to stop talking and uh well per
usual her argument was full of lies and
nonsense if we take a closer look at the
incident that took place on September 6
1990 we begin to see holes in her story
in September 1990 Marge was enrolled at
South Forsyth High School in Georgia
when a fellow student held hostages at
gunpoint she claims her high school was
a gun-free school zone because of
Biden's gun free school zone Act of
1990. in 1990 George H.W bush was the
President Joe Biden was a Senator and
Biden wasn't even a co-sponsor on the
bill it's also not possible to blame the
September 6 1990 incident on this bill
since it wasn't introduced until October
27 1990 and then signed into law on
November 29 1990. so unless Marge is
traveling back in time and rewriting the
events of History this is a huge hole in
her Story come on man and when it comes
to the incident itself the witness
accounts tell a different story than
what Marjorie Taylor green is now
telling Marjorie Taylor green claims
that her entire school went on lockdown
however non-hostage students were
evacuated and bus to a nearby Elementary
School and finally while records do
indicate that she was a student at the
high school during that time she
definitely was not one of the students
taken hostage and according to the
school spokesperson her attendance on
that day could not be verified honestly
I wouldn't be surprised if she was
stealing the traumatic experience of her
former classmates for political gain and
relevance because the first time she
ever told the story was on the house
floor in February 2021 she had to defend
herself and her past remarks like when
she called the Parkland school shooting
a false flag operation or when she
harassed David Hogg a Parkland school
shooting victim and how did you get kids
why do you use kids
why kids you know at school if school
zones were protected by with security
guards with guns there would be no mass
shootings at schools
do you know that
is with a good guy
but yet you're attacking our Second
Amendment so now whenever there's a
school shooting Margaret Taylor green
make sure to tell her news story about
how she was a victim of a school shooter
here she is on Tucker Carlson in May
2022 in response to the deadly school
shooting in Uvalde there was no adult
there with a gun in our school because
our schools had turned into gun-free
zones this is because of Joe Biden and
the crime bill that they passed back in
1990. the only reason that Marjorie
Taylor green does this is to advocate
for more guns in schools which we know
doesn't work and if you look at the
recent school shooting in Nashville the
Covenant School reportedly had one or
two staff members carry guns on a
regular basis and even they couldn't
stop it bottom line Margaret Taylor
green has repeatedly used this news
story as an excuse to blame Joe Biden
even though it had nothing to do with
them you know just like the time that
she blamed Biden for the fentanyl debts
that actually happened under Trump's
presidency it's a common tactic used by
Republicans to own the limbs and it
backfires on them almost every time and
most recently the topic of guns was no
different you know there are six people
that are dead in that school including
three children because you guys got rid
of the assault weapons ban because you
guys made it easy for people who don't
deserve to have weapons who are mentally
incapable of having weapons of war being
able to buy those weapons and go into
schools I voted for sros in my schools
in in Florida after Parkland we have
sros on every school did the good guys
with the guns stop six people from
getting murdered no but you know what
AR-15s you've seen what those bullets do
to children you know why you don't hunt
with an AR-15 with a deer because
there's nothing left and there's nothing
left of these kids when people go into
school and murder them while they're
trying to read you guys are worried
about banning books dead kids can't read
well until next episode I'm Gabe Sanchez
and this has been what was that if you
enjoyed today's episode and want to
support the work that goes into creating
the what was that show you can join my
patreon at whatwizthatchow.com you'll
get access to early episodes exclusive
bits behind the scenes content access to
the show's private Discord as well as
live q and A's to connect directly with
me to offer up comments questions and
suggested topics to be featured on the
show thanks again for watching and I
hope to see you over on patreon
oh there you have it the newest
what was that on on YouTubes on the
tubes of you on the tubes of you you
know where you can see this though just
like you said there at the end where you
can go see it is what was that show.com
that's what was that show.com it'll take
you directly to Gabe's patreon make sure
to go over there and give him support in
this content that's how he creates it I
love that beats Captain it looks like
like a like a late show type thing yeah
yeah I mean and I'm making some changes
I got some new stuff planned uh so you
know we'll see me we'll see a whole new
studio there's a whole new studio I
can't wait to show you uh right you know
are you actually you're building it like
a physical one right yeah I'm building a
physical Studio
let's just say that it's a mobile Studio
A mobile student mobile Studio God and
one that uh one you know with the goal
of you know like just like the mobile
Studio it's to get the content out
sooner right because this this it take
you know I gotta write it and then I
gotta film
and film this time no I know so I'm
working just all the AI and the I know
so I'm working on ways to get to get
more like you know breaking news content
or stuff that comes out you know that
day how long does it take you to write
one of these to be you know I how long
does it take because I know you're
constantly working because I'm like hey
man we get we got this and he's like
look I'm [__] writing yeah I'm
filming or something so yeah yeah I
could take you to write one of these
um let's see I mean these typically
range from anywhere from like a nine
minute to a 16 minute
like video
and if I had to guess the writing
process
like probably takes a couple hours or so
because I've got a I've got the initial
concept and then I just go through the
Eve like what like for the here we'll
break this one down for example what I
had to do was there was the the back and
forth that happened right and then uh I
said okay well this is crazy let me do
some research into Marge Hitler green
because that's the thing you're not just
like writing this and then like well
I'll just say whatever I want like right
exactly like no I gotta I gotta know
every single detail he goes right looks
up and resurges every single thing so
then I look up all right people this guy
the detail I tell him to stop but he
can't he can't he can't quit so I I do
you know not like Margie Taylor green
but what I have to do and in this case I
look up I look up the school shooting I
research the the the witness accounts
from the actual students there the
police you know
um I I look up uh several different
factors and then I you know I start
looking into to all the times in which
she which she told this story right
because it's been a recent thing that's
happened in addition because the first
time we talked about this the other day
the first time she told the story was
when she went to the floor to apologize
right after the videos resurfaced of her
harassing David Hogg and saying these
crazy things you know the conspiracy so
it still wasn't the exact story that she
kept telling right so there's been kind
of changing yeah there's like slight
changes so then I went through and you
know I found the I didn't want to play
that one because it was a long drawn out
like right oh I'm the victim and I was
like normal Marjorie Taylor green
exactly so then I found the one where
she was on uh Tucker Carlson there's
other accounts in which he's told this
story uh in different venues but I was
like I only need one to show an example
here uh and then in addition to that so
not only am I looking into the accounts
of that day in which she claims the
shooting happened not the shooting but a
shooter took over and locked down her
school because what happened was they
were I think it was nine students or
there are a thousand students total at
the school or 1200 or something like
that and only a handful of students were
actually held hostage and even the
shooter himself didn't want to shoot or
injure the kids
uh he was having emotional issues the
parents weren't supporting him so like
there was a lot that was revealed
different than what Marjorie Taylor
green not to not to downplay a shooter
right but the story that she tells is
very different than what actually
happened well
um
when these when these laws started to
first come about after a lot of school
shootings
um in the late 90s
and they started passing a lot of these
like um zero tolerance for guns of
course I live in a rural area so a lot a
lot of times like during deer season a
lot of the a lot of people go hunting in
the morning before school right and
there's several people that got in
trouble because they have their rifles
in their trucks because they would come
from hunting and go straight to school
and there's a lot of people got trouble
for the zero tolerance
um rule which there should be Zero
Tolerance of firearms on school property
right B it's not that hard not to have
it I think the I think the law if I'm
gonna raise a thousand feet within
school well like right well I mean each
each State's going to be different yeah
yeah but but again again they're rolling
back all this stuff right yeah yeah
there's actually a there's actually a
bill that is being proposed to roll back
uh the gun-free zones at schools right
well and and even in Tennessee we see
today we're going to show some videos
yeah because we have a guest coming
um um to talk about and what subject is
the guest talking about today and who's
there the the desk the desk the guest is
Dera Faye she was on last Friday we
talked about the restrict act right if
you haven't watched that you should go
watch that or at least look into the
restrict act and what's going on today
we're going to be talking about the
which I believe just passed yesterday
actually which is the Idaho
uh abortion trafficking bill that was
that was signed into law okay that's the
one that's like a lot of buzzwords in
there basically illegal to cross you
know the whole like will find you and
we'll penalize you if you if you try to
get abortion elsewhere right yeah so
it's abortion trafficking so we're going
to talk about that and then on top of
that there's another bill there's a
state Senate bill in Kansas yes that has
been uh that is now up uh for uh to well
to pass because we had one Democrat
in the Kansas state legislator
to um
to to help push that forward so
basically that bill is the one that
allows not not uh not doctors not
medical professionals it's it's School
administrators to uh to have a physical
exam of girls to make sure that the girl
is a Girl by their standards so what
that means is a non-medical professional
a not a doctor not a nurse nothing like
that means a school administrator
is going to pull down your daughter's
pants or skirt or whatever and make sure
that they're actually a Girl by their
standards in order to play sports wait
wait wait wait wait it is almost like
we said that they're targeting women and
and girls in this and not not so you're
saying they're not worried about what's
what's in boys sports they're not
working no no they don't care about boys
they don't care about boys that's the
church the church cares about boys but
wait wait a second oh oh that she's
gonna check their Jenna daily right
right which yesterday there was even a
there was a huge reveal that happened
about all these cover-ups too not the
topic for today we can talk about that
another time if we want or if that comes
up and Dara wants to talk about that
that's silly Vine but the two topics
today are the abortion trafficking in
Idaho and the Kansas State Bill uh
around allowing School administrators to
look at little girls genitals now and I
gonna get more details on this uh
this Kansas bill yeah but
how long have I been saying that they're
obsessed with Jenna Taylor yeah
why that's that's that's the thing too
is like we've talked about ever since
Roe v Ray Wade right uh pass or was
overturned in what was it June of 2022
right I mean even before that there was
the possibility is it going to get
overturned there was the leaked uh
opinion that got out there you know it
was we saw we saw the writing on the
wall right and we talked about it on the
show and the biggest thing was you know
we we talk in hyperbole but hyperbole
isn't hyperbole when it's the truth you
know right and it's like oh you guys are
being so extreme they're never gonna do
that you know you talked about condoms
being you know banned as contraceptives
in a in a case I laugh I laugh because
everyone thinks I'm crazy what are you
talking about man right and so then you
look at what's happening now and it's
literally the aspect of pulling down
pants or skirt or whatever and being
like are you a girl or because because
why because Republicans are incredibly
triggered by the fact that a very very
anything they're triggered by anything
anything but a very small percentage of
the of the girls that are playing sports
in school
may be transgender and I think let me
just uh uh let me double what other
proof do they have to say have then
other than I feel like that person there
I'm hyper focused on their genitalia
that I can't see and it feels like to me
it's a penis like that's literally their
thought process they're they they are
they're upset that they're serious what
how in the [__] okay how the [__] can a
parent or a school administrator or
teacher anyone go to a middle school or
a high school basketball game whatever
it is girls basketball game
and be completely focused on what
genitalia is it how sick do you have to
[__] be
I mean disgusting like there's no way
around it I mean the fact that you're
trying to you know not you but these
Republicans and one Democrat okay so
let's call that out as well we have one
Democrat who agreed to say oh yeah you
know what I will support this bill the
fact that there are these people right
is is gross but also really plays the
idea that they're obsessed with your
they're obsessed with genitalia and uh
and the other thing too the party of
save the children save the kids we want
to protect the kids like you don't go
about that by looking at their genitals
you know what anyone like like you're
opening up you're opening up a a a spot
in the law where any sick [__]
who has the power to do this can just be
like yeah I'm challenging every single
person what's to stop them right it
doesn't because it's the [__] law at
every point every Point you're gonna
find I mean like you know I think I
think some Republicans are you know as
as constituents are seeing this as like
oh that's that's really [__] up right
if we were to bring it down I mean who
isn't saying this is [__] up I mean
the size of people oh no I know but I
mean the people who are not saying this
is [__] up are those who support the
bill and then probably a lot of
religious people right using the
religious like umbrella of we're doing
this for the kids and to keep things
safe and this is how God intended it to
be only men and only women and yeah but
see that's a bunch of [__] because
here's the thing here's the thing this
is like the bathroom argument they had
and here's the bathroom argument back
again right the stupid idea that oh I
you can't look trans women go into the
women's restroom you mean you mean
people who look like a woman go into a
room where only women go like I I
honestly our Taboo in this country over
bathrooms is [__] weird anyways yeah
like we're in there to go to the
bathroom or like do a bump a Coke off
the sink or something you know I'm not
judging I'm not judging no
no this this number I'm just saying uh
Dara might have an updated number for me
but this is from 2021 and this is
talking about uh transgender
uh students playing in school right and
so it's just like like States state
sanctioned sports like basketball yeah
yeah yeah this is this is high school so
it
I don't know what the number is for
grade school but for high school it says
a report by the Human Rights Campaign
found that only 14 of transgender boys
and 12 percent of transgender girls play
sports given all of those numbers it's
statistically possible that there are
some 35
000 transgender student athletes in high
school which would mean
0.44 of high school athletes are
transgender that is what they're focused
on they're focused on oh no no they're
focused they're focused on how can they
how can they make it to where they can
demean women oh yeah because this ain't
about the boys because here's my point
about the bathroom right when you have a
transgender man someone who has a beard
looks like a man is by like man dressed
like a man
are you saying because the walls you're
trying to pass
you're saying you want that person who
looks like a man wearing man's clothes
has a beard or has the body of a man you
want that person to go into the bathroom
with your with your underage daughter
that's what you want because that's what
you're doing right
when you're passing these bills that's
what that's what you're saying you want
I mean and all the breath they're like
I'm not gonna have no goddamn man going
to the women's bathroom with my daughter
like that like no literally that's what
you're doing yeah when you're saying I
want to protect children save the
children you can't sexualize children
well stop
thinking about their [__] genitalia
right to stop the sport the basketball
the the sports ball that you want to do
ain't got nothing to do with genitalia
there's no [__] special move in
basketball where you do or don't use a
[__] in the move it doesn't exist I mean
it's it's also the fact that like if we
go back to the whole swimming like
Obsession right what we need to whenever
you hear people
uh talk about how there's a transgender
athlete in sports right I mean one they
don't want to look at the actual numbers
and say oh there's actually again point
four four percent it could be a little
bit higher now but also less than half a
percent
of transgender athletes in high school
okay that less than half of a percent
and that's what sound sounds like right
yeah yeah but even smaller than that are
the ones that they're really focused on
which is the you're not really a woman
right because of you know yeah they're
not they're not they're not worried
about a trans boy or trans man they're
not yeah they're not they're not they
are not because here's here's the other
thing they don't want because I think
there's also this insecurity right let's
say that uh a male transitions to female
right a transgender female and they
compete in sports and that uh
transgender female is better at the
sport than their daughter okay there's a
lot of insecure parents who instead of
accepting the fact that this this person
has decided that you know what I feel
more comfortable as a woman right I
transition I'm a transgender woman and
instead of being oh look let's accept
everyone for who who they ought to be
right who they want to be like good
Christians let's [__] love thy
neighbor
however
what they're so concerned about is their
own ego their own insecurity just like
when they say oh CRT and they're making
my kids feel guilty no they're you're
white it's your wife
it's you feeling insecure and and and uh
and guilty and ashamed or whatever it
might be when really at the end of the
day it you're you're projecting that
onto your kid you're saying the kids are
complaining that the kids are saying
this blah blah it's it's so dumb because
it's only the parents that are the ones
that are bitching about it because it's
only the parents that are concerned
about they're you know trying to live
vicariously do their kids and and
project their own insecurities onto them
and say oh well you know my daughter
needs to get that Ribbon or that trophy
or whatever instead of like the best
person compete it's no no my daughter
should do it because my daughter's a
real daughter and it's like you can go
[__] yourself with that language
uh Texas pollens here in the chat he
says damn Tony just put a whole new
meaning to posting up I think that
refers to my uh what do you use your
[__] for in basketball yeah I've I've
never I mean I've played a lot of
basketball in my life and I've never
actually used my genitalia in the sport
a mask I don't know if there's a sport
that you actually use your genitalian I
don't think maybe I'm wrong but I don't
think there is I don't think there's I
don't know I don't know I mean I get
some people consider sex a sport so
there's that oh really that's a sport
yeah is there like a competition like
World Championships there's probably a
sex-a-thon you know really I don't know
man I have no idea
are you just making this [__] are you
just making this [__] up and just to get
a reaction out of me yeah yeah because
you know I'll give you a reaction if
that's what you want uh but I don't know
you know it's it's uh you know it's
whatever it look the at the end of the
day and we've got Dara in the in the in
the in the green room right now there
she is yeah and so again she here is she
ready or give a thumbs up
can she did she like no she's like yes
no yeah okay all right we'll give it a
go and yes you want to add her in yeah
yeah go ahead go ahead all right just
introduce introduce yourself what you
can talk about first yeah
what yeah I think we'll talk about Idaho
yeah go ahead but for people who uh who
are here on Friday Daryl was here
talking about the restrictions she's
come back uh to talk about a couple
different a couple different bills that
have either worked this time or yeah I
did uh that in Hyde Idaho we've got a an
abortion trafficking Bill and then we've
also got this let's call what it is
right it's a pedophile bill in Kansas
State
I'm glad to have you back yeah so tell
us about tell us about what the hell is
going in Idaho first I want to know what
the hell's going on they they're using a
lot of buzzwords on this uh abortion
whatever the hell they're calling it
trafficking abortion they like they like
to have buzzwords in there it almost
makes me feel like this is projection on
their part two I'm sure that's what
you're gonna say but let's get to it
what's going on in Idaho well I mean
they signed it yesterday like quietly
right yeah it's like a chaotic thing
um
so the bill is that you can't I have
questions about the bill too because I I
read it over and there's some stuff
where I'm like hold on so basically the
bill says that um
you could be I think it's up to five
years in jail and like twenty thousand
dollar minimum fine if you
bring a minor across state lines for an
abortion without parental consent
um
is it gonna stop there though are they
gonna start being like you need both
parents concerns yeah no I think they're
gonna I mean I'm sure I'm sure like with
when you know overturning Roe v Wade
this is like they're like all right
let's let's take a step closer and then
each time they'll be like all right
we're gonna add an amendment to this
bill and we're going to add an amendment
an amendment to his point where they're
like all right you can't even breathe or
think the idea about an abortion without
being penalized you know but Teresa on
Facebook
I forgot airpods did can you yeah yeah
is it clear should I get my airpods
okay sorry
uh go on Tony well no I was gonna say
Teresa brings up a good point here she
said so much for parental rights because
you were talking about consent and I've
said for the longest time that that's
what the the taking away women's bodily
autonomy and even going after trans
people and and drag shows for that
matter that's that's people and books
Banning books that's them eroding away
at your parental consent over your own
child because that's really what they
want they want consent of the miners uh
the the government wants the consent
right big government as it is is that
what the way the way the bill is worded
it really leaves it to
um a point where if someone is receiving
abortion pills in the mail
and someone drives them to get it
whether they know or not they could be
charged with abortion trafficking wait
you're you're saying the people driving
the person to the mailbox well they're
minors so I have to assume I can't drive
so if someone took them to like the post
office to pick up a package or something
potentially they could be charged
what the [__] wow they're they're
trafficking abortions
trafficking is well but yeah here's
here's the point is that like when you
said that just now because I'm like what
abortion Services because I'm not I'm
not a I'm not a woman I'm not a female I
I don't I don't I don't seek abortion
services so that's why I don't dictate
to people what they should and shouldn't
be right that that's one of the problems
I think we have as men in this country
think they have the right to come in and
be like hey we're going to tell you what
to do even though we don't know [__]
about it because when you said go to the
Post Office that's why I was like wait
why why in the hell would someone but
then I thought oh what you're saying is
is some sort of an abortion service that
maybe uh um a prescription right yeah
they're not they're not doing performing
DNC like surgery at the post office
that's what I I didn't think so I mean
there might be some because of this law
right well it could be maybe in the
alley of the post office but see that's
that's the point the point I'm trying to
make is that a lot of people that are
making these laws they're not serious
legislators and they're and they don't
know about these issues to be making
laws that restrict these things right
these choices that we have of health
care because that's what women are
seeking here is health care I I I I
think a lot of people get that Twisted
but what you're saying is because of how
this is billed anything that is an
abortion service right no matter what it
is even if it's not the actual what most
people would consider an abortion right
you're saying is going to be under the
purview of this lawn it's gonna really
put people people in legal Jeopardy even
if they want to take them to a post
office box because they're like hey I
need to go to the uh the post office can
you take me there and they have no idea
yeah I think the bigger not the bigger
but an equal and almost larger concern
here is that
um well this bill's probably gonna get
challenged right someone's gonna
challenge the bill but then it's it's
gonna end up in our current Supreme
Court so they very well might rule in
favor of Idaho and that's going to
affect everyone now you know like we
it's it's it's look what just happened
with Roe that's how we got here right
and that that's the thing is that this
is really gonna could potentially affect
everybody not just women in Idaho
yeah I think I think there's a you know
you you brought it up a moment ago too
is like you know how far will they go
with this right and you know kind of
like what we talked about the restrict
act last week the idea of like what is
the intent right you might think or how
it's written currently to be like all
right these are the protections because
we feel that these are appropriate from
the Republican Party
but there's also you know the way in
which you write it they might be like
well we've purposely had this we wrote
the semantics this way so it could be if
it's challenged then we could expand it
or we could interpret it even further or
or imply that the intent was to have all
of these things and the idea that it's
like I think it says harboring as well
uh and transporting we're recruiting
harboring or transporting which is like
what the [__] okay again Republicans
think that you're recruiting someone to
get an abortion yes we have abortion
Cults it's a it's a chapter of antique
that's that's the Wednesday meeting
right not the Thursday meeting okay
right okay I show up on the Thursday
because of the food but I didn't know
that we had a whole like a whole
abortion meeting that we could go to too
we also do wishing
oh okay I see them well you know that
that makes sense that the chat is asking
here like how are they going to track
this and and I want your answer but I
want to let the chat know that in the
state of Missouri the the the the
um head of the Department of Health that
that our Republican Governor put in
charge of he had a spreadsheet that he
was keeping track
of women's periods yeah I I mean I know
that sounds great because it is gross is
he married and
wouldn't you like to meet her I mean
it's creepy it's creepy it's [__]
gross right the fact that you're gonna
track you'll be like oh let me just go
into my [__] lookup table and Excel
right now and try to figure okay I got a
matrix here to match this person with
this location and this time of the month
we have a Dar witness the reason why
when Roe was overturned that they were
like delete those apps because we talked
about a gate delete the app I don't have
a period tracking app because I don't
last one you should and I think we all
should and I think we should I what make
it up should I just put it in there
that's not a bad idea what you're on to
there so you're like just post up fake
data that way it's it's just uh like a
mountain of fake data and they can't sit
through it not that I think that if it
was actual data that they'd know what to
do with it but right well they that well
I mean it's like Ben Shapiro they don't
know what to do with a whop even if they
could find one you know you know
okay so I guess we're um down to the
genitalia now so tell us about this
Kansas what happened in Kansas yesterday
because apparently the governor vetoed
this thing said [__] no she she vetoed
that damn thing but it was uh it sent
back to the legislator and they
overturned it is that right yeah they
vetoed are they over they overruled the
right
that's a whole right issue so keep in
mind like Kansas is now the 20th State
to have a ban on transgender children
participating in sports that are
consistent with their
um identity their gender identities so
that's not unique to them
but it's so funny because like the all
the states that have it are exactly the
states that you think would have this
um and Kansas was like wait that's our
crew and
so it's just I
all right with Kansas their bill is very
um like I made a video yesterday and I
just sensational
[__] out of it because
you not yeah surely not you
but like the reality of it is this is
discrimination
and yes it's going to lead absolutely
opens the door to Predators coming in to
get the perfect dream jobs for them
um because you can really write anything
off and being like well that kid we
suspect might be trans let's bring her
in
I mean
or they could say we're going to do a
random check of the whole team wants to
Stomp Them yeah they it it's really
vaguely written and and it doesn't
really unless I missed it specify how
they're instructed to I don't see this
this information now if it said like buy
a birth certificate I'd be like
yeah okay I mean it's still invasive I
don't agree with it but like
that is less invasive than like hey let
me let me drop your pants right right I
mean I I think uh I I when I was reading
through it I don't I didn't see any
specific language it's just kind of
General it's very vague to say like if
we believe or if we know that this
student is a transgender female then we
can inspect them uh
to to verify it's just like it or to to
keep it's I think what was the language
like to keep you know female sports safe
right which is like or Fair it's [__]
absurd and it's complete projection and
it comes I think it if we break this
down to me it looks like it comes it all
comes down to like money okay so hang on
so we have all these families that are
like hardcore into like my their kids
sports
and they're the ones who are going to be
like we just lost it's probably because
that kid on that team is transgender
check that she has a vagina and it's
like but why are you so worked up with
that why are you so what's on the line
for you and what it comes down to is
money it's it's sponsorships it's
scholarships it's Partnerships that's
why they're worked up it's not just
because of the game it's not because
they just love the game it's that they
hope that their kids are going to get a
free ride off the game and now they feel
that that's jeopardized by people anyone
who might be better than their kid
they can claim is transgendered and
needs to prove and actually I I go ahead
I was gonna say yeah it was something
that we actually mentioned right before
this which is like uh
I can see you know there's those parents
that like you know they peaked in high
school senior year they were the captain
of whatever team and then that was it
right but they still live in those The
Glory Days the good old days where I was
you know King of the school or queen to
school or whatever right and I think a
lot of these parents too also not only
money but they probably feel you know
lit like they they use their child to
relive that experience vicariously right
through them to be like oh you're gonna
win that trophy but it's not you winning
that trophy it's me winning that trophy
right I put all this hard-earned money
to make you the best athlete to be
rewarded and I'm gonna make sure that I
get my money's worth or I'm gonna make
sure that I get my ego boosted right
which is a sad and pathetic thing to see
that parents like I get caring about you
know how your child does and you know is
active and all that but like there's
definitely a line that's crossed when
you're now
like really living through that kid and
everything they do in a sport right we
all saw a little giants ends yeah
exactly right it was exactly like that
you brought up something that again I
haven't even thought of in this case and
the reason why is because with with
these stupid ideas that that Republican
GOP has where they're living out their
fantasies in some respects it seems it
seems with their projection that that it
would the inspection would be done after
the game after their their little
snowflake got their their ass kicked in
the game and they'd be like oh what
couldn't be because these girls are bad
hats because those girls have wieners
like like everything everything is is
the fault of a drag show right oh well
it must be those woke woke genitalia
over there in the basketball uniforms
right because I didn't think about it
that way I thought about it like oh well
that we can't play against them because
that girl looks a little too boyish so
we want to have that player checked
right but but what you're saying and it
makes sense is after the fact the
parents get their feelings hurt or the
students get their feelings hurt and
they trudge the whole team in to see who
has what genitalia to see if that had an
effect on the game right so like it just
it's all these weird ideas that get
planted into their brains about
something that has been going on for a
long time and they haven't known this
though like this is It's almost like
they think trans people were invented
yesterday well they're gonna you think
about like
teenagers and even younger I mean this
is not limited to right High School
right five-year-old t-ball which is like
girls are probably stronger than the
boys at five but
you know it's gonna extend all across
that whole age range and
I can't imagine like I was a tomboy
I can't imagine someone coming to me and
being like we need if you want to keep
playing soccer we're going to need to
make sure you're a girl because you
dress like you're you're wearing like a
lot of baggy pants
do you know what that would have done to
like me mentally I think yeah that would
have [__] me up and they're okay with
doing that even just asking that
question even if they didn't have to
show anything and it was just simply
going to the doctor and the doctor being
like I've been your pediatrician since
you were born and writing a note like
the amount of judgment
yeah a girl would feel
right this is like they're they're gonna
cause trauma just by asking that because
that's the other thing having to prove
it physically or not it's it's gonna
it's gonna mess a lot of kids up that's
the other thing it is about the girls
it's about it's about the girls it's
about the women yeah girls I had a lot
of comments on my video yesterday mainly
on Tick Tock but like the bar is set
really low intelligence wise on Tick
Tock
you know you were you know you were
advocating last week to keep Tick Tock
and now you're talking about the uh the
bar of Intelligence on Tic Tac I mean
two things can be true at once right I
mean you know and
um I had so many comments people being
like is this satire like the one video
of mine that isn't and asking me like
are you serious boys always get their
genitals checked in physicals and I'm
like
okay but this bill's about girls yeah
I'm like well this feels about girls and
girls do not that is not a thing they
don't go and check for a hernia right
right because that that that's a good
point because I was talking to my wife
about this yesterday when we heard about
this and I I told her in the state of
Missouri Misha is the is the association
that that is in charge of uh School
sports right Public School sports like
that's the State Association that sets
the rules sets the boundaries and in
those boundaries those student athletes
have to receive a physical and part of a
boy's physical is to check for hernias
and when you do that a a medical
professional a doctor not some [__]
weirdo School administrator who doesn't
have a degree in medicine and know how
to check for a hernia that is the person
who is doing a check for a hernia and
yes during a male hernia check you
generally have your pants down and they
they check and have you turn and cough
that's the I wonder why they're checking
prior to you playing doesn't it make
more sense that you're gonna get hernia
because of playing isn't it weird yeah
well
that's a good point into Tony's uh
experience like I was talking to DARE
about this yesterday he's like I I never
I don't you don't you didn't get one you
didn't get a physical you might have
blocked out the trauma yeah I might have
just like oh don't touch me uh I wasn't
traumatized but I knew I do remember it
was the doctor that I had my whole like
my growing up you know like my
pediatrician doctor yeah but for me like
if I if I call back or like try to
recall the times I had a physical it was
always like oh we're gonna check your
breathing we're gonna check your heart
we're gonna check your weight your your
height like all those typical things
we're gonna make you know if don't have
any problems whatever but like there's a
part of me where I'm like
I don't remember having like a physical
physical where like we're checking
everything until like
I was much older right like maybe into
high school is when I was having those
types of physicals maybe I had one as a
young kid but there was a gap in time
where I remember going to get a physical
every year for school and not having to
have those things checked because I just
probably because it wasn't specific for
sports but that's the other thing is
that you can get a physical in the
beginning of the year and you're cleared
for Sports for the whole year right and
I guess it seems like that's different
than if you're going in specifically for
a sports physical because your last one
was I don't know like I'm not really
sure but again it doesn't make sense to
check for a hernia prior to you playing
the game that might cause running I mean
kinky streets break up brings up a good
point like HIPAA much like these are you
would think that all of this this this
bill would would violate HIPAA right
like you're not a medical professional
you're not your medical professional
your pediatrician or your your your your
your your like family physician you
would think that this would be some
pretty violating I mean like you know
it's just like okay like just to put it
in your perspective for anything else
medical conditions that schools ask like
asthma or if you have medications for
some kids have to take add medications
throughout their ADHD medications
throughout the day whatever it's kind of
falling and I guess it would fall into
the same category because in order to
play something that you're not required
to be playing this is what we need so
you're either gonna sign off and wave
that hip you know what I mean you're
giving that consent it feels it feels I
mean it feels like a big difference and
I feel like we all agree here one's
different to me like hey it's 3 P.M or
it's noon here take this medication
versus drop your pants and let me look
at your you know right they didn't
specify in the bill that and that's part
of the problem they didn't specify that
it has to be done by a licensed Medical
Professional accredited pediatrician
whatever it was just like like anybody
yeah they're like oh the janitor is
going to come through and inspect's like
no well what if they start bringing the
Pastors in that's right whoa well and we
know on your Twitter page the pastors
could definitely be a problem we have
the best audience in the world here and
they have some of the funniest responses
and Steve says um in the comments he
says this is nuts thank you
if you there's a when you're in here I'm
sorry I can't hold on do you see a
comments button on the side
yeah yeah
that was like if I wanted to leave notes
to you guys no no we have a private
that's the private chat here look here
you have some great comments yay
and then a Texas Paul is in here Dara
thank you so much for all you do so you
got you got fans in here my friends
does vaccine is solid and he he shares
Texas Paul shares those things yes Texas
Paul is a is a warrior for democracy and
sometimes uh shining the light on some
of this or just a warrior you know I I
think you know for the work that you
know Bex and daradu in terms of like
this type of stuff like not just
democracy but also just [__] human
rights right like right human rights to
be like hey this is my body and you
don't get to violated or or you know uh
take away my own privacy to for your own
[__] desires or whatever like sick
Obsession yeah so we violate their
privacy yeah they all love you here in
the chat so good responses so go go
follow Dara on Twitter and you'll see
her feeds go find her on Instagram
everywhere you'll see her videos
do you have a link tree do you have a
link tree I do but it's in my Instagram
profile and my Tick Tock profile
okay well I'll get that and I'll after
the show I'll put it in the comments or
in the in the description below we'll
put Dora's link trees that way you can
go follow her on all the socials what do
you got one more thing yeah I wanted to
I'm just have you guys seen Democrat
messaging pushing back on these bills
because I haven't seen much
uh last night when they were okay so
when we were chatting offline yesterday
like I didn't know that this bill
had been proposed in 2021 and that
people were talking about it but the one
specifically in Kansas uh and and then
started digging into it but I didn't see
anyone really talk about either one of
the I mean the abortion trafficking one
I heard like in the last few weeks I
want to say but the Kansas one I didn't
hear anything and both of them you know
happening on the same day uh
I heard a lot of people talking and
bringing attention to it
um but there was this you know it's like
what's the next step like that's the big
thing of like how do we
how do we fight back or how do we
challenge this uh but it wasn't it was
only until yesterday did I see everyone
and maybe it's because I was looking for
what I wanted to see or whatever in
terms of these you know this bill or
this uh being signed or this bill being
proposed
um but I feel like yesterday was the
first time I saw either of these things
or at least just the Kansas City one
um come up
in terms of people being upset right
I'm wondering can like Democrats whether
it's they can do it or not should they
just start screaming out into the void
that like now we need to can you stop
is that your cat it's it's yeah what's
your cat's name uh sassy oh that well
that makes sense yeah
um it's funny because I had a Siamese
and she was not named sassy and I don't
know what happened there I just I didn't
think
um if the Democrats could just start
yelling about like
we're going to start putting a ban on
requiring
requiring uh genital checks for sports
like I don't know if they can but why
not start throwing it out there yeah why
not write some bills to uh ban this
stuff yeah it's gonna go nowhere right
all right I just look draft it up and
start shouting it out I mean I just want
like you look at how Republicans they're
fantastic at messaging it's it's sick
the way they do it the fear-mongering
but like
what's going on with Democrats yeah no
that's a good one you need to take some
notes from them and start like no that's
that's I I agree with you I think um
being loud and proud because every day I
don't steer away from the word liberal I
think liberalism is strength right and I
I believe I believe that democrats
should stand for their ideals and their
principles of democracy and part of
democracy is making sure that just
anybody and everybody or old Pastor
what's the [__] his name uh gets to
[__] check someone because he thinks
she doesn't have the right genitalia in
her basketball shorts at a game that's
not [__] we should be doing that
violates other people's Liberties their
rights and their freedoms and the the
freedom to oppress the rights of other
people is not Liberty that's at the
beginning of the show hell we got
t-shirts with that printed on it but
that's I I think I think that's why
um it's important to follow you on
social media because you are holding
these people accountable and yes you may
not be a Democrat elected official and
you you I don't even know if you're a
card-carrying Democrat or a Democrat
that that is funded by George Soros you
know like like they all claim we are but
the point is the point is is this is
that we all have microphones and you use
yours very well and I know the chat they
love you for exactly what you do on
social media and everyone can do their
part everyone can do their part I mean
we we watch what's going on in Tennessee
today and yes is it a travesty of
democracy what is going to happen if
these three members are expelled and I'm
not sure if they are not yet I don't
know exactly when the vote's going to
happen
um yes is it going to be a tragedy in
democracy yes but is it gonna is it
gonna test us
the pro-democracy Coalition people who
want democracy who want freedom and
rights to be the vehicle to Liberty that
we so seek for equity and equality for
all then then yes this is a test and and
we need to be tested it is us the people
because we are the government we are the
Democratic party or the Republican party
or whatever the [__] party there is it
is us it is we
and we are the ones who are are the
voice of this country and yes sometimes
in these deep stupid places in the
country the minority ideology of the
country Reigns and it has power but we
can fight back we can I I said it in the
first 30 minutes what we should do is
Democrats and blue States should say
we're going to gerrymander the [__] out
of these states every single District
all of them blue we're getting ready to
fascist in our state we're not going to
have it if you don't like it go [__]
cry somewhere and I'm telling you the
the day the day that Mark Elias has to
file lawsuits against the Democratic
party because they're gerrymandering too
much is the day the Republican party
will lay down their sword trust me on
this when they're on Mark Elias's side
and Mark Elias is on their side there's
Republicans will understand the risk
that is taken because right now there is
no risk because I agree with you Dara
that the Democratic party and and the
Democratic Coalition does not lean and
push into this and push into this
Fascism and call it for what it is there
a bunch of [__] pedo Nazis no one in
their right mind would think that it's
okay to just run around checking [__]
children's genitalia at sporting events
pedophiles would think that's okay
though well right that's why I call him
pedo Nazis you know because you know
look at what's going on in France right
right all because of what pensions
retirement age Yeah by two years three
years and look at them fighting
meanwhile we have some serious like [__]
going on here and everyone's like well
time to check what Meemaw said on
Facebook about this and then
[Music]
who Meemaw is that is that her name I
don't know I'm not on Facebook
[Laughter]
everyone's just bitching online not
necessarily talking about us but like a
little bit and like and where what we're
going through is huge what's happening
here and everyone's just like taking to
the internet I mean the kids went out in
Tennessee like what like 10 000 of them
last Friday and they got ignored
right the kids are the ones out like at
what point do we all just go
just say [__] this [__] and go go tell
them you either change it or else yeah
is it working in France
I don't know I don't know I just saw
they took over garbage though yeah I
just saw that they I saw a video today
where they were inside of uh I think it
was BlackRock which is yeah it was Black
Rock in there yeah he's a [__] company
yeah yeah they're they're the ones who
uh purchased a lot of real estate during
the uh during the lockdown for covid and
then are trying to pump up or inflate
the market they had a huge loss which
was great but
um yeah I think I saw a video and it was
it was them there was just a bunch of
[__] fires inside this building the
French don't play yeah yeah yeah Day
poster yeah but the French don't [__]
around man and only over two years which
is insane to think it's just two years
and again to to your point it's like
over here we've got Health Care things
that are happening we've got education
things that are happening we've got gun
violence things that are happening
and I think a lot of it is like
not to say that people are numb to it
all because I mean like humans were not
built for this much stimuli right this
is like so many bad things happening at
once but I think there is a part of it
where people are like holy [__] like
what do I focus on because there's all
these fires happening and I think that's
you know I think to your point earlier
like what what is the Democratic party
doing and it is like there are so many
fires that the Republican party is
starting and as the Democratic party or
anyone on the left you're like looking
around trying to figure like well [__]
do I put that one out or this one out
first or like I put that one out but
then this one got bigger and now I I
can't I can't control
right exactly like it's you know it's
there's a it's like the cartoon where
you're plugging holes in a wall and the
water keeps coming out of different
spots like that's what it feels like and
in a lot of days where you're like holy
[__] I I don't know what to [__] about
or call attention to because there's all
these things and everyone has their own
priority of like this is important to me
because of this reason or this is
important to me because of this reason
and it's just like the Republican party
is a is a party of chaos and destruction
well you know that's part of their plan
right yeah that's part of their plan is
to keep as many holes coming out of the
wall as possible so that we have to keep
plugging each hole and eventually we'll
get exhausted and we'll give up and just
let the room flood that that's that's
part of their plan well their plan is
flawed because while we might be
physically drained after years of our
since we were all like early teens like
late middle school early High School to
now it's just been one thing after
another like we're all just like [__]
and we're drained but gen Z is all
they're gonna start voting and they're
they're they are not trained like they
were born right into this like fired up
yeah you know they don't have dreams
that have been defeated because they
didn't have teams to begin with
plans and dreams for our lives are you
are you saying it sucks to suck and we
suck is that what you're saying oh yeah
yeah like we had we had the ability to
be like we had we're like all right
anything's possible we're good and it
was like nope that's squashed we even
had the best we even had the best
generational name it wasn't even a
goddamn letter we're just like we're not
even gonna take a letter it's
Millennials [__] that's what we're
gonna do and we're like we're really
cool we got a name it's not just a
letter and then it just got all [__]
right
is gonna be the the one thing that
they're not maybe that maybe that's the
trouble is we didn't take a letter maybe
we should have taken a letter maybe
ourselves the Boomers did well of course
they did oh [__] she's going on the
Boomers the chat's gonna light up now
ding ding ding
the chat just lights up
yeah
I want to go to some of this footage in
Tennessee because I want to show the
audience uh what is happening in
Tennessee uh as well so Dara thanks for
joining us again thanks for keeping us
update on on Idaho and this Kansas thing
uh everyone go follow Dara on Twitter
and and go to linktree I know the mods
have been putting her link Tree in there
so go follow her on any social media
that that you're on and uh keep track
because she does great satire videos and
she keeps track of some of these as we
call them pedo Nazis so thank you Dar
for joining us all right let's get back
you know what let's take a quick break
let's take a quick break when we come
back we'll get to some of this Tennessee
footage down there and down there in um
the capital of Tennessee we're going to
watch do you know if it's happening yet
if these three members have they voted
the vote I I have it I'll here I'll send
you the link okay it's currently
happening as we speak okay so they're
giving let's go to a break let's see if
I let's go to the break let's see if I
can pull up some of this video we'll be
right back right after this
we'll be right back Mark
60 seconds this is the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket I've got
you covered part in blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard in blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardons not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome back to the show I'm watching um
Justin Peterson right now
for the Tennessee legislator we're gonna
go
do some of that footage here to see
what's going on
I'll be trying to vote to spell three
members of the Tennessee legislator for
standing with protesters who are all
they're wanting all they're wanting is
just common since gun reform like red
bed red flag Rose background check let's
listen to Justin but I haven't seen it
yet either uh is is unfair and it's not
that difficult of them to ask
thank you Mr Speaker I do wish to
correct one of my responses to my friend
from Davidson County uh this bill HB 306
uh takes effect upon becoming law
it does not
take until July 1
2023 to provide this additional
protection for children in private
schools in pre-k through 12. that fact
ways in favor of having it attached to
the bill today and voted on today on its
substance okay so what it feels like to
me Gabe Sanchez is um they're actually
um they're working on the bill where
they're trying to provide more funding
to private schools so State funding to
private schools for some of the measures
that have failed uh in public schools
um where they I believe this bill that
they're talking about now is the one
that gives uh State funding for teachers
to be armed in schools I believe that's
what they're debating right now so this
doesn't seem like the expulsion vote
yeah
um so we'll keep an eye on the floor
there in the in Tennessee uh legislator
you know I thought of a I thought of a
while we were talking or one of the
because I wanted to get the Tweet out uh
I see you know how in New York there was
stop and frisk right mm-hmm well I think
what we should call what these
Republicans are trying to do in schools
right is strip and frisk oh
right because that's what it is right so
you're saying what you're saying is kind
of what Dara was saying what do we do is
you're saying we should message it I
mean let's call it strip strip and frisk
because that's what it is right you're
you're now as
a [__]
obsessed you know pedophile uh you want
to strip and frisk a child
with you know because you
are insecure your your uh
your your just a a a
disgusting human who has their own
desires that wants to justify it or
excuse it as something else right well
let me ask you in the state of uh Kansas
right say you're a parent and they
change the law right by overturning this
veto
um and and allowing just anyone and
everyone apparently uh to play with your
your child's genitals and a sports event
because they want to specifically girls
what is a stop them at sports like what
oh there's no stopping them so so if
they if they make this okay and they
make this normalized in sports what
stops this and I I don't know maybe it's
uh maybe it's drama and then music I
mean are you going to say are you going
to say whoa whoa whoa wait a second my
son was supposed to carry the bass drum
and the band in the marching band right
but it seems like that this person now
is carrying the bass drum and it feels
like to me she's a girl and she got it
but she's not really a girl yeah so what
why why why is is she playing the tuba
can we figure out if if her sheep
playing tube has anything to do right
because I want to know I mean what's to
stop them what's the stop them at sports
I mean there is no stopping at sports
that's the thing that's the that is the
um that's the point right the way in
which it's written all of these bills
are written is that you're going to find
them using this as an excuse to be like
well now that I'm in their pants in this
situation
yeah I can easily see how tangentially
Sports is an extracurricular and an
extracurricular also has choir
drive like you said like all these like
I could the same way they do CRT like in
math and Florida they're like oh it said
CRT in the book so yeah we're gonna
happen ways they're gonna find ways
because like oh how do I get more access
to these private things right and you're
going to find them say well now that's
passed let's also add this amendment or
you know or or what they'll do is
they'll you know say hey you should go
do this thing and then when there's a
challenge right legally because what
they want to do is you know instead of
us being like Oh let's look at all these
other things that are uh are include
like should be included they start with
the first thing right and then they wait
for someone out there to you know push
the envelope then somebody says if
there's nobody if there's nobody you
know pushing back then they're like all
right great we can keep doing this but
if someone does push back and they go to
court then they say well this is clearly
in the purview of this type of activity
so we should totally make sure that it's
totally fair right that it is a boy
playing a boy's part or a girl playing a
Girls part in this play despite the fact
that [__] beer had men women all the
time right so let me just say because I
like your strip and frisk and I like
that we need messaging around this I
added I added some other ones in the
comments I saw some I saw some from the
chat so if you're on Twitter feel free
to add your own we've got stop and grope
we've got stop and drop uh we've got
another one that was added drop them and
grab them like you know yeah well here's
because last night when I was having
this conversation with my wife I said I
was having that conversation
um
she said oh boy will this please all the
sanduskies of the world do you remember
saying yeah so here's my thought Here's
my thought on messaging why don't we
just we just rope in this whole
obsession with gender and pronouns and
wokeism and drag shows and children's
genitalia in the one nice little sick
package for these people why don't we
call it the Sandusky effect
it's the Sandusky effect right these
people are weird they're creepy they're
they're wanting to do weird [__] with
your underage children
and they're trying to hide it they're
trying to make it seem okay I mean why
not call it the Jim Jordan effect right
it could be yeah I do we should you
should name it every we should put their
name on there say it's the Jordan effect
it's a Sandusky effect right it's uh the
plenty of other people that are known
I'm sure that you could bring up steal
it from me if you want I'm serious go
out on social media right now I think we
should I mean you know taking a page out
of you know uh Dr Rachel bidikoffer's
book which I'm sure she's gonna have in
as a chapter right or like or there'll
probably be several chapters yeah yeah
is we should hands down right find ways
like she you know she's like we should
mock them we should call them out we
should rank you know the other thing too
is
we should dumb this [__] down right they
say oh well it's to protect you know in
Kansas they say it's to protect uh women
actually let me let me go one sec I can
tell you the exact language that the
bill has in Kansas and I can tell you
exactly you know what it means and so
they're using
uh Kansas City state legislator it's
hb2238 if anyone wanted to go look it up
it's creating the fairness in women's
sports act to require that female
student athletic teams only include
members who are biologically female okay
it's a bunch of triggered parents who
went out and told the school
administrators that it's not fair that
their daughter didn't start because
their daughter isn't good enough to
compete right and so they're trying to
remove anyone who might be a trans woman
from playing those sports right whether
it's on your own team or the competing
team right it's the whole big lie [__]
where it's like we gotta find a problem
the other team cheated and it's complete
projection and so clutch them and touch
them yeah I mean go to Twitter and
[__] spread this [__] wild right
spread it like herpes as Tony would say
yeah spread it is like Derbies all
around the internet that we should be
give them nicknames call them out name
these bills after these people that are
known for these sexual acts right or the
sexual perversion and call it out
because
if there's one way to make people
uh feel weird about it is to is to call
it what it is right not to say oh the
fairness in women's sports what it is is
it's the
um hold on wait somebody wrote here
the pedophile protection laws right
that's what they are right somebody else
said the schlap effect again right
what's to say that the master the master
effect someone was saying about Larry
Nasser yeah what what's the the gates
grab bill I mean we should be giving
these bills the names that they actually
are right and and if they feel so mad
about it that's not what the bill is
called that's not what the Bill's about
then explain what it's about explain
that you want to give non-medical
professionals access to Children's
privates their genitals so they can
expect to be like is she really a female
because you're you have this weird
pedophile like obsession with vulnerable
children and being like well man if I
had any opportunity to do this it would
be under the guise of this fairness and
women's sports bill that's been proposed
right so yeah we should be calling this
[__] out give them names give them
nicknames make them feel embarrassed
make them explain themselves on why it
shouldn't be this thing or it's not at
all this thing in which we're naming it
right they should have to explain
themselves as much as possible because
everyone who supports this yeah should
[__] have to explain themselves
exactly if you support it you're a
pedophile I mean [__] say it I know
again
we say like early on you know oh we're
speaking hyperboles but like hyperbole
becomes truth in fact very quickly
within the Republican party as soon as
something is proposed
then it becomes you know this thing that
we say oh well it's gonna go here and
everyone says no it's not it really does
and we're seeing this right now
well that's that's the truth and we have
to message around it we have to get it
out there you remember when they were
taking uh Ivermectin oh yeah and it was
it was 2020 and they were taking
Ivermectin and everyone's like what the
[__] why are you taking horse pace and
all this [__] and it almost stopped it
almost stopped immediately when we
started mocking them and the reason I
mean not fully there were still some
boneheads like well I'm going to take it
just to own the libs like okay or all
right like yeah like that'll work but
they it almost stopped it almost stopped
immediately like there was there was
um
a shortage of horse dewormer
in States like like veterinarian groups
like The State associations and [__]
were putting out
putting out big memos like don't sell
this to people who aren't using it on
their horse because you're going to
cause a shortage of this [__] it's like
there's only enough your your covid will
be worm free but right but the horses
won't they're like look this doesn't
work this way you people are boneheads
don't take the horse face I mean it's in
some instances people are going to the
feed store and getting sheep drench yeah
because it have Ivermectin in it because
because sheep have worms in their in
their wool so they they give them a
drench to get rid of parasites in their
wool before they
you know that you know Trump loves the
uh the uneducated right he he loves to
tell people hey you know how we deal
with covet we get a little sunlight and
we inject some bleach and people are
like oh hell yeah or like when people
are talking about uh hydrochloroquine
right there was a there's another one
there's a there's a uh a sister I forget
the full name but it's used as a fish
cleaning product and there were those
two people in Florida that took in the
[__] done right but here's the thing
is we mock them we mock them on social
media on on on on mainstream media
places late night shows they were mocked
heavily that these people were taking
horse paced Ivermectin dewormer that
doesn't help covet it doesn't even make
any sense like it doesn't make any sense
at all why you would take it like even
on its face it's dumb as [__] yeah I
remember when Joe Rogan's like I take
avermectin and people like what the [__]
Aaron Rodgers Aaron Rodgers was one of
the the Superstar quarterbacks and he's
a [__] joke now no I don't even no
one even takes that guy [__]
seriously because he's like well yeah
there's there's some validity and taking
Ivermectin like get the [__] out of here
man he's like I consulted he's like I
consulted well that was the other thing
that right but here's I don't know what
doctor you have but she's well but
that's the thing is that if we mock them
it moves the needle folks yeah it really
truly does move the needle now I want to
go to Tennessee here yeah I saw someone
ask for the live feed yeah um uh so
let's see if we've got what we got going
on here if they're I it's probably
they're still on that one bill but I'm
going to show you
um a couple Clips here that I had this
morning I want to show one of um
yeah they're they're just they're just
voting on item 28 right now it's sb8
okay so they probably won't get until
now later this is the past let me see if
they have generation
um but here yeah I know I'm not sure
when they have the vote scheduled uh let
me pull up a uh a video here uh let's
see where can I find it here
um yes this is the this is the Tennessee
three as they're calling them uh here
are the members of the Tennessee three
this is them
um walking into the chamber with the
crowd they're the protesters
you guys
feeling okay
[Applause]
[Music]
so there you see them entering the
chamber earlier uh and then uh the
representative Jones uh came out let me
see if I can find that um that video
here I thought I had it ready to go
sorry about that there's just so many
videos that were happening today
where is it I'm trying to find I'm
trying to find like there's an official
time but I'm only seeing the the the
name soon it's happening soon but right
well and it's probably on the docket and
I'm not sure which item it is again
they're on unfinished business yeah
they're on unfinished business right now
so I'm not sure if they're uh if they're
going to move to a different item it
could be possible that they do not that
they do not make the move to vote on
this expulsion yeah um with with the
pushback that there is uh here is here
is uh Mr Jones He represents part of
Nashville
um but here's him speaking to the
protesters earlier they're trying to
pass these small Solutions about locking
up schools like fortresses having more
police in schools but what these people
what we've been asking for is common
sense dunlops to take these weapons that
we're off our street so they're doing
all this to justify their expulsion of
us after they say oh we did something
and so I just want people to know what's
happening and that this is a this is a
spectacle that this is the far so this
is the circus going on and then this is
not this is not real solution so we're
gonna try to say is we did something but
what we said is we needed to do not just
a minor cosmetic Band-Aid but we need to
do real surgery on the issue which is
the easy access the firearms and so we
hope that we continue to hold them
accountable
um they won't even let people clap for
the Republicans are able to act unruly
and do whatever they want today so there
is there is a trajectory to expell us
the sense in there the this feeling this
that the Lynch Mob was already assembled
in here and so we know no matter what
happens they're not going to silence our
demands they're not going to temper our
demands they're not going to make us
afraid to speak but I just hope that
people see what's going on in here and
there are some in here who have already
been coming up trying to antagonize her
trying to get a response from us I hope
people know what's going on in the
people's house and I hope they were
holding accountable police fall solution
yeah we're with you
so there's uh Justin Jones the
representative uh in the Nashville area
or one of the representatives in the
Nashville area for the state legislator
he's one of the Tennessee three uh and
brother Jones as he's known on Twitter
um and gave his speech there I think I
think it's important for people to
understand because I realize that
because when this happened the other day
I got a lot of people sending me
messages like oh my God this is fascism
democracy's dying listen folks well let
me let me tell you something
I want to give you I want to give you a
little bit of positivity here
because this isn't democracy dying
this is democracy being tested by
fascism they're testing us they're
testing us how far we will go what we
will do to defend our democracy and if
if we will use our power that we have
within our democracy to protect it and
engage in it they hope that we do not
protest at state capitals they hope that
these Tennessee three would just resign
and move on and they can pass whatever
bills they want to oppress the rights of
people in their state which is not
Liberty
and they were trying to do it all around
the country in Florida and in Texas and
in Alabama Louisiana
and it won't stop there and it won't
stop at guns it won't stop at taking
away your health care won't stop at
taking away your bodily autonomy it
won't stop at taking away your right to
be who you want to be wear what you want
to wear they're not going to stop there
they're not going to stop at your
parental consent of your children they
will not stop
and this is only a test this is only a
test and we the people must engage and
pass this test it is our test to pass
they are testing us
and they I'm telling you they're not
ready for this new generation that's
coming they're terrified of them I mean
after after the Wisconsin Supreme Court
vote this week the calls were oh we
gotta lower we got it we got we got to
lower the our raise the voting age we
can't have these 18 19 year old people
boating they're lining up in droves to
vote against us right because they're
pissed off at us because they hate us
because we're trying to oppress them
and oppress what they want the country
to be and they have the [__] right
they have the right to believe what they
want to believe be who they want to be
have the Liberty they want to have and
they have the right to engage in our
democracy and use democracy to save it
and that is what they're terrified of
folks that's what's happening in
Tennessee that is what is happening
that's why they want to expel three
members they're terrified of those three
members talking to their constituents
and God forbid that those three people
agree that the State of Affairs when it
comes to Tennessee's gun laws and the in
the prevention of gun violence isn't its
best right they're really [__] in the
bed here and all they did was agree
that things need to be changed and they
and they said you know we support the
people we have support these kids we
support these students these families
who want to change the gun laws to make
it safer not not put more guns into
schools because we know that doesn't
work
but the fact that we need to have uh
Stronger restrictions smarter
restrictions uh safer restrictions like
we need to make sure that it's not
anyone can get a gun and anyone can go
shoot up a school because of whatever
and the fact that you know these these
Democrats looked at at the problem and
said
this is an epidemic that we can help
prevent and we can help stop and
mitigate right now
we shouldn't have kids dying and
Republicans are like oh [__] that [__]
you say one more goddamn thing that
supports the people that are dying then
you can go [__] yourselves and get
expelled and that's what the Republican
party wants they do not want them to
speak up and speak up for the people who
are hurting because they don't care
about the people that are hurting they
only care about themselves and the
nra-backed you know lobbyists and and
getting the money here and getting
influence there they don't care at all
so when we see people stand up and speak
out we should be doing more of that you
know even if your voice is only on
Twitter that's good enough even if it's
sharing this this this show or sharing
the news or sharing about a petition or
whatever it might be like if you can't
do you can't get out and March in in
protest that's fine your voice matters
online and the ability to share those
things matters even more right the fact
that you're engaging in democracy voting
right like those things matter and they
make a big difference right we've seen
it again and again and again ever since
2020 through the 2022 midterms these
special elections showing up and voting
does help and it prevents a domino
effect of a fascist state of Republicans
trying to force their own wants and
desires and sick obsessions on to
everyone else because they are a small
minority trying to carve out a majority
stake
I couldn't have said it better myself
everybody listen here's one thing that
you can do you can listen every single
weekday Monday through Friday noon
Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific right here
on YouTube Twitter and twitch do not
forget to subscribe to the Tony Michaels
podcast if you have not already and
download every single episode on Apple
Spotify Google give us a great review
while you're over there follow us on
Twitter while it still exists at Tony
Michaels pod if you have Facebook still
if you got an account at the Tony
Michaels you can follow us over there
make sure if you have an Amazon Prime
account that you take advantage of your
one free subscription and link your
Amazon Prime account to your Twitch
account give us that one free
subscription we get a few dollars of
Jeff bezos's money I'm just saying and
if you want to support us monetarily the
best way to do that for me and Gabe is
our extra content over on patreon check
out our patreon Pages that's patreon.com
the Tony Michaels or patreon.com I am
Gabe Sanchez you'll see all the extras
and all the extra access there to us for
that monetary value
did I miss anything you got it man you
know why and today is Thursday which is
Thursday
we'll be looking for that be looking for
that poll I don't know if Elon I think
the 15th is when he's gonna change the
polls on Twitter right so we've got one
we've got more we got this one and then
we'll see and we'll see if he changes
that I don't know he could yeah he could
he could Buck to the to the pressure
right yeah he'll probably buckle and if
he doesn't then everything will be over
on YouTube yeah so again you're not
going to want to forget to subscribe to
the Tony Michaels podcast YouTube
channel because the the the bone end of
the week poll will live there if not on
Twitter until tomorrow when we have bone
in the week in the second hour same time
same place Surf's Up [__]
you've been listening to the Tony
Michaels podcast in your face commentary
of current events and political news no
rules No Boundaries I I think we've made
that perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed
the show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[__] them
[Music]
Murphy's mealborn headass Beacon